السيد الرئيس ، أشكرك على ما قلته
واه
[موسيقى]
أنت تمثل رئاسة
الاتحاد الدولي للاتصالات ليس الـ 12 زائد بالطبع ، لذا
مع كل الاحترام
لرأي أو وجهة نظر 12 زائد ، نحن بالتأكيد
ندين أي احتلال وأنا  أنا
أتحدث من بلد
احتلناه قبل 30 عامًا ، لذا بالتأكيد ندين
أي احتلال ولكن في نفس الوقت
لا أحد وأنا أتحدث إلى الـ 12 بلس
من
خلالك أه كيف يمكنهم أن يطلبوا شرح
طرد
الوفد الروسي  أو أي
وفد آخر من الاتحاد الدولي لوسائل الإعلام
لغزو وقع قبل
أيام أو أسابيع ولم يطرد
الإسرائيليين وهو غزو وقع
قبل 60 عامًا ،
لذا فأنت
تعرف الكيل بمكيالين ولا أعتقد
أنك رئيس  يجب أن تقبل مثل هذا الشيء
ما لم
يتم طرد أي دولة تحتل دولة أخرى وأنا مع هذا
النهج شخصيًا ،
لذا
عليك فقط مشاهدة أن
المعايير يجب أن تكون هي نفسها
ولا يمكنك قياس الضعف  قياسي أه أه
ونعم كان ذلك
تعليقي وأود أن أشكرك على موقفك في
هذا الموقف
[موسيقى]